[Music]
another game with white
and again let's try to play another
scotch gambit
let's play another scotch okay so
philidor great
now when phasing the philidor we
apply basic principles and
it's pretty much common knowledge the
main move here is to play
d4 and open up the center
bottom line rationale for that is that
d6 is a passive move
it's not a horrible move but it's
passive because it closes down the
bishop
doesn't develop a piece the logical
response to that is to open up the
center
okay knight d7 that's a move
and the problem the secondary problem
here is
when you develop passively you just
don't have the resources to to defend
sometimes against a very quick onslaught
and you should associate onslaught in
the opening with the f7 square because
that's the only accessible square
so knight c3 is fine but if we wanted to
go for the quick
kill what should we do
bishop c4 is correct good
black should probably take by the way
yeah so
knight f6 is already bad see and this is
the problem uh
well it's not terrible but now we can go
knight g5 and he's gonna have a very
hard time to defend against i mean d5
e takes d5 and we're just up upon now
maybe there's some sort of theory here
that i'm not aware of but i think this
is just bad
to be honest
well this is the fried liver but it's a
worse version for black because
he's more passive okay
knight b6 is good but
where should we go d6
has the cart before the horse our bishop
is actually hanging that's a good
thought this should be
three is possible but i like the bishop
b5 check move because
c6 is not possible here we just take it
and if he goes bishop d7 we take it and
we basically win another tempo tempu
you know this is the kind of position
where we want that extra tempo
to develop more rapidly all right
and don't overthink this position we
need to understand what's what's going
on here
okay so we're probably going to lose
this guy so if we're losing
that guy well c4 doesn't work he takes
if we're losing that guy we might as
well take this guy
and be up upon okay so he defended very
well here let's castle
and develop he's probably gonna cast
along but we are up upon we've got a
nice position
sometimes you gotta tip your hat i mean
sometimes the opponent defends well and
this is going to happen increasingly
more often as we climb the ranks well
i spoke too soon i think this is a mouse
slip although i will be honest h6
would have been equally as bad because
we would have made the same move
regardless now
the fact that he hasn't castled is
setting the alarm bells off all right
any situation where you have cast living
your opponent doesn't sort of by
definition is a situation
where there's a heightened chance of
tactics
and again there is a pattern here which
is quite common
which is the notion that if his queen
ends up on the e file
and the e file gets open then we'll be
able to play rookie one and so
combining that yields the move e6
he is forced to take we take with the
knight he and he cannot well he can but
it is inadvisable to take with a queen
because we got rookie one
okay
yes hey daddy
all right um
he's in trouble the king is in trouble
much the same way as our previous 96
right it's preventing
the king from yeah and so he decides to
take but
now this is not over he should take our
rook and get
at least a piece and a rook for the
queen but the reason that's bad is
because his king is just so
weak and he just resigned so yeah got
off on the wrong foot there
okay so that's the philidor
um the as far as i know
them well there's a couple of things to
to understand about this position
um the very common trap bishop e7 is
often played here
as a way to try to stop knight g5 and it
does
but after d takes c5 amazingly black is
almost lost
because if d takes e5 what is white's
move here and we've just
we just saw basically this exact
pattern no this is my last game guys i
don't know i'm pretty wiped windy five
yeah and again he's got a click we
literally just saw this
and if he takes with a knight then
we take his knight and we play one move
well you can bribe me but i i wouldn't
refuse the bribe but i
will still go to sleep it's so it's not
here okay
and see you you have to be concrete
you you know when you're applying
patterns from one position to another
you have to check okay maybe this
position is a little bit different and
here you gotta see
the bishop defends the queen but notice
that this is an undefended pawn
this is upon which is under pressure
combining the two yields queen h5
which is a classic fork it's actually
very hard for black to even find an
adequate defense equine f7 he's got to
go here
that is an ugly move queen takes e5 and
now you can go here and this position is
horrible for black so in addition to the
pawn
this king is uncastled it's around plus
two according to the computer white is
basically winning
i've actually fallen into this myself
with black so
the best move for black i think is to
actually just take the pawn and say yes
i'm worse i've got less of the center
but i'm pretty solid here
all right i do love my breaths proudly
so
so i think that there's probably
some theory behind this and i think
black can play this in a better way
i think this is asking for trouble and
desert pagal gifting to photon 6.
so he actually played okay until this
moment
but if he would have castle long
i think funnily enough um
we have a very powerful move in this
position and again if you think very
straight sometimes you want to play very
straightforwardly
if there are situations where you just
want to pile up on something and it just
works
and this is one of those situations
where you make an exception to the
development rule just go queen f3
and he basically has to try f6
but now we have what
sequence of moves if you're very
attentive
to the patterns here you notice this
queen ah we want to get a knight here we
can't do that immediately but we can go
e6
intermezzo boom fork
winning so constantly modulating between
applying principles and also knowing
when to violate them is
one of the things that makes chess so
exhilarating you never know
these kinds of moments are wrong the
point is to know when these moments
arrive
why not e7 at least 70 takes it
or the bishop yeah well queen e7 doesn't
help we go knight f7 anyway that's the
point right the pawn defense the knight
and if he even gets to this night he'll
be lucky
okay um
now that is why in the modern version of
the philidor
black takes he takes d4 this is the best
move
and generally the modern players fiance
of the bishop like this
this is a legitimate variation one that
is not easy to break
and um it is actually
quite a hotly contested line black needs
to be very accurate there but it's
it's not like a refuted line by any
means
yeah and also like there's another
version of the philidor which starts
like this you go knight
6 knight c3 5. okay
and the reason is because if you try to
do knight f6 here which
is a move then you run into the
additional option of white taking
and to my knowledge this is a bad this
is considered
very dubious for black
1348 we play solidly with black
um let's play another cara let's play
another cara
and cairo is of course sinbad ferry i
think for the prime
and he goes e5 now if you guys have been
watching my blitz there's two main moves
here for black there's c5
which is the sort of the new move
and it's been gaining popularity lately
but of course the
main move the traditional move the move
that we are going to play is bishop f5
and
we were talking about this earlier this
is precisely
the line that a lot of people struggle
against because it is a closed
center and this requires
knowledge of typical ideas for black and
knowledge of how to play we've had this
before though so hopefully
um you guys feel a little bit more at
home here those of you have been
watching the speedrun
now what is black supposed to do here
what is black supposed to do here
what's next so f4 is not great it's very
weakening
it blocks the bishop yeah so e6 right we
need to cement
the center we need to open the bishop up
we need to make sure that we're not
going to get steamrolled
and those of you who play the french
this is just like a french setup except
our bishop is
outside the pawn chain that's the whole
point we pay for that with a tempo
in the french who plays c5 often in one
move here it takes two moves bishop d3
so already we have a battle going on
over the f5 square
and taking on d3 would be fine but
i don't want him to have the possibility
of playing f4 f5 very quickly that might
lead us uh to some trouble
so this is exactly the concept of
trading on our own terms i don't want to
give away
the f5 score easily what does that mean
well
that means that we can develop a piece
and simultaneously bring the square
under our protection
a lot of you are pointing out knight a7
i like this move but
what i don't like is that it blocks the
bishop in and if we fianchetto
then our dark squares particularly the
square on f6 becomes
really really weak we can circumvent
this by playing knight h6 now i know
what you guys are saying
aren't knights on the rim grim and i
think i talked about this the thing is
this knight's going to end up on f5 most
likely
it might be a matter of a couple of
moves but
this is frankfurt airport we're going to
f5 at some point
so don't think of this as a knight on
the rim think of this as a transit point
to f5 but h3 is a very bad move he
sort of forgot to castle forgot to
develop his pieces
and now he's going to pay the price when
h4 check forces his king to move
doesn't win the game or anything but
obviously it's it's
pretty much a no-brainer corn on the cob
thing for the prime
and he's going to have to decide where
to put his king
yeah so king f1 is
the best move king e2 other moves i
think are quite a bit worse king d2
would
give up the f4 pawn thank you uh the
final wave appreciate the prime
thanks guys for all the support king f1
now speaking of frankfurt airport
uh that's the analogy that i always have
right to describe these
these ideas you know when i would play
in tournaments in europe i'd always fly
san francisco frankfurt
frankfurt's a great city but uh you move
on toward your destination whether it's
paris or rome so
what should we do yeah we take the
bishop now we take so knight g4 some of
you guys are seeing
and let me just label this move so i can
talk about it afterward it doesn't work
well no it's not that it doesn't work
but why can't just defend
f2 with uh with queen e2 and then i
don't see a follow-up we don't have
enough pieces
to make stuff happen with so instead we
take the bishop
and how should we follow this up he's
going to take with the queen
and then what should we do yeah i don't
like frankfurt airport
knight f5 yeah and there we go
all right
all right queen takes d3 knight f5 now
we're threatening nitro3 so he
his best move would be to develop his
knight to e2
and simultaneously cover the square on
g3
now i remind you guys the specific
questions i'll address after the game
goes knight f3 that's actually not
not so stupid because if we give a check
on g3
which i know a lot of you are tempted to
do he's going to slide the king over to
g1 and the problem there
is going to be that our queen is hanging
and we've got to move our queen and that
knight on g3 might get a little bit
stranded there
he has an h2 square for his rook
so in such situations exercising
restraint
can be very you know can be a very good
idea
so i propose a move which
will cause some eye rolls let's dip
let's get the hell out of there the
queen has done its job the king is weak
you know his king side is in is in
shambles
we're threatening a fork now but
we need to repurpose this queen now for
potentially an attack against d4 let's
not forget that the main idea of the
karo khan in this position
is to then play c5 and under minus pawn
so this queen can swing around to b6 and
attack from
a distance all right
yeah we can play h5 to stop g4 depends
what he does
but we don't actually have to knight c3
okay so he misses the fork no reason for
us not to win the exchange
you know in some situations you would
consider not winning the exchange if the
knight is
strong but it's it's not particularly
good there
so okay so what should we do now
if we really want to play in solid style
if we want to play in a style that
does not permit any ideas what should we
do
even before we do so a lot of you are
saying c5 but
this is actually a brief danger zone
because white's developed two pieces
we've developed zero
so what i'm really worried about what
move do you guys think i'm worried about
here if it's white to move let me put it
this way
if it's white to move what does white do
here what move am i really concerned
about
queen e4 yes f5 right f5 well it opens
the bishop
it it attacks e6 i don't like it i don't
like the look of f5 and i'll talk about
that afterward
why f5 is scary but for now take my word
for it it is scary
y is i'm just writing all this down
so what should we do about it
what can we do about the threat of f5
a move that looks bad i warn you
prophylactic
yes g6 let's prevent him from going f5
now i mentioned previously that a move
like this is the drawback of weakening
f6 but he can't access it
this square on f6 is inaccessible
because e4 is protected by the pawn
even if he accesses it we can get this
bishop either to e7 or g7
and it can stand sentinel over this
square so the
negatives i think are greatly outweighed
by the positives here
so g4 is is a move but remember that his
king is already weak there's no rook
there to protect
so this would be a win for us because
then if he plays that okay he plays five
anyway
well we should take toward the center
let's not take with the e pawn because
then we might allow his e65 pawn to go
forward
so let's play gf
now i see what he's trying to do here
thank you will uh
who will ask for cash to cajun tiermann
maybe he wants to develop the bishop
with tempo but it doesn't really do
anything we'll just play bishop b7
yeah castling is weak but we might
castle long or
we might leave our king in the center
okay knight a4
yeah okay it doesn't really affect what
we what we do
let's just get our night out we don't
even really need to play c5 anymore
we're up material
so the priority is shifted our priority
now is just to complete our development
in a timely manner and get our king to
safety one way or another what am i
already thinking about here okay knight
g5
we've got to be careful let's break this
move down does it actually do does it do
anything
is there a threat i don't see one
despite the appearance of this move it
doesn't have a threat
so i think a lot of you are probably
thinking about h6 here
but and h6 is fine it forces the knight
back
we can actually use this position to our
advantage instead of just going h6
why don't we develop our bishop and
simultaneously attack the knight then we
kill two birds with one stone basically
and then a follow-up idea is to prepare
castle long
and then use the g-file for an attack
but hold your horses these gone queen g3
i think that's a blunder
he's put the queen and the knight on the
same file
pinovich and winovich
i mean that's the name of an nfl
official an image
nice
okay h6 is the threat yeah
h4
change six wins the night and the game
yep whenever there's a queen and a minor
piece on the same file
and that file is open or semi open you
don't have a pawn on that file you
should be
contemplating whether that allows some
sort of a tactic
well it will be up a row because
remember we're already of an exchange
so if he goes 96 that's a good move
because if we take the knight then our
rook is undefended so we have to be
careful
but we take his queen takes on e6 we
take his queen
he takes our queen then we take his
knight at the end and not only have we
traded queens which is good but we've
also won the knight
and yeah
okay
thank you blitzkrieg thank you
appreciate it
yeah love hearing that that's awesome
man
that's incredible progress 1218
okay so
straightforward logic here
thanks guys
okay 96 played now again we don't take
the knight because the rook is
undefended
we have to take the queen
and it doesn't really matter what we
take with but if we want to be super
clinical here's a tricky question for
you guys it doesn't matter
but if you want to be clinical which way
should we take
there's an interesting logic here i
think king
right because we want this rook on g8
and so
the fastest path is to get this king out
so that we can then go
rook g8 um
but yeah no this is fine because bishop
f4 we have rook g4
attack that's an important detail
otherwise he would have had
well actually he can go e6 but then we
can still go to g4
yeah perhaps i shouldn't have allowed
this but it's it doesn't matter
i don't think i've laundered because
the bishop being undefended i shouldn't
have played this move but it's
it's fine because rook g4 attacks the
bishop if you go cc he might go e6 but
but we just take the bishop he takes our
knight answers to trade
okay now g3 would be the best move here
for white
yeah gasoline when the queens are off
the board is not nearly as important
and i would i would put it this way if
you're castling when the queens are off
the board sometimes
it's for king safety purposes but other
times
it's just to get the rook involved more
so than the king
to safety
i'm not sure what that means lawful okay
but okay
i'm not sure what you're what you're
getting at but all right
that's i i do start my streams with hey
guys
okay so this king is stranded in the
corner
so we can play i mean anything wins here
p6 is fine
but i like well either rook 8 shade or
bishop f2 let's go rook hd let's set up
the discovery
bishop f2 checkmate if we had gone
bishop f2 first
he might have gone g3 and opened up a
square for him on g8
on g2
this is over yeah yeah it's winning
yeah and again i know that some people
prefer blitz and i
i played a lot of blitz you know that
will always remain the focus
okay check we can do anything we want
here we can give a check and win the
rook
we can check and win the night let's win
the night just so just
so i don't have a heart attack over over
this pawn
because you know we're just gonna do
this
well it's called a speeder if anybody
doesn't realize that yet it's
the speed run is a sort of a mock
of a real speedrun thank you cno
but i think if i called it like a slow
run it wouldn't have that
zing to it you know so yes i took some
creative license let's check him here
and if he goes up we check mate him on
f3
it's a brisk no i mean i'm i'm 1300 it's
not like we're taking forever
all right 100 bits thank you that was a
rich game
so f4 not a great move again
because he's focused on
protecting the center which is
understandable but the center is well
protected enough
it's time for white to focus on
development which is why knight f3 is
the main move
and the main line is just to play like
this although there are
just countless setups in this position
for white
all right so f4
e6 bishop d3 not h6 so i think this move
should make sense
to everybody again we're not keeping the
snyder nations we are eventually going
to go to f5
and we are opening leaving open the
diagonal for the bishop which is
important not only because the bishop
can come out to e7 but also because
it makes it easier for us to then go c5
all right h3
mistake white should just develop with
knight f3 and white's position is
totally fine here
then we would have gone c5 we don't have
to rush with taking the bishop
all right well g4 oops sorry well g4 is
not possible i mean
this square is protected but we'll get
to that
so if he plays bishop d3 here no knight
h6 here he can take it
see that's another reason why f4 isn't
great here we
here we have to take and go for this
position
right and then go c5 but if he goes f4
then yes that h6 is a very reasonable
move here
all right so f4 e6 bishop d3 knight h6
h3 check takes knight f5 very simple
now some of you wanted knight g4
and i get the temptation of this move
all right and it works if white takes
because if he takes now you don't want
to take the rook you give up the bishop
then
you have to take here and then take the
rook even this is not that simple
because y
can go f5 but the reason i rejected this
is because of a very simple move right
this threatens checkmate
that's all it does so why can't just
like we need to
we need you to defend the square and the
issue is that you're going to run out of
gas
it's a very dangerous situation a very
common mistake
um you know when you're first starting
it's exciting
to spot tactical patterns so
this for example is exciting it's
stimuli it's stimulating it early yeah
knight g4 and it's totally
understandable it's a nice it's a pretty
move
but you gotta uncouple sort of how nice
a move looks
from what it actually does um it sounds
a little bit harsh
but the only thing this move does is
threatens checkmate on one square
and everything else is undefended so at
this point black is going to pay the
price for this because the knight is
still very vulnerable and the queen is
very vulnerable
and this is premature yeah yeah
so does this make sense
are there any specific questions about
this now if bishop takes d3 of course
you don't want to take with the queen
you want to take with a pawn yeah ruin
but okay you're j this is just one pair
of double pawns it's not a big deal
and now you have to drop the knight back
then white develops with tempo and then
i can go g4 so it's not worth it
and you know also these ponds are
actually kind of good
you know why because
it's like a snake that molts you know it
sheds its skin
and it replaces it if black goes c5 here
what happens why are these double pawns
actually kind of good who can tell me
and this is a pro a serious pro of
having these double pawns
he can undouble but not only that then
he can play d4
and all of these efforts have been in
vain so
you can shed your skin and then you have
something underneath basically now
of course you could argue well black
wouldn't go c5 here but then the center
would remain closed okay
double pawns can be a phenomenal
protective force okay
so knight of three again if we check him
then
he goes king g1 and this knight is going
to be
stuck in no man's land okay
so queen d8 knight c3
okay he should have gone king f2 now we
might have gone h5 to prevent
him from going g4 right we stir or we
could go c5 here and we could meet you
for with knight takes d4 opening up the
center and this king is going to be
really weak
it's your binky thing for the eleven
months all right
so why is that f5 scary now let's say
we would have gone c5 first of all if
you know between this and something like
bishop b7 i would have preferred
something like 97 because we're not
developed
but if you think about it the king is
weak
f5 breaks apart blacks pawn chain and
opens up files
and can be followed up by night g5 i'm
not calculating here i'm just sort of
intuitively concluding that this is
scary that's that's part of chess you
can't calculate everything
so i think you guys should be seeing
what i'm seeing
which is that what's why does the lead
in development and white's
breaking open the position not something
i want to allow and that's why
we take time to go g6 does that make
sense this is a
i think quite an important point
so when you've the lesson here is that
when you've won material
take a moment to identify sources of
danger just because you're up in
exchange or peace doesn't mean
that your opponent no longer has any
threats
all right well that depends hamer i mean
these kinds of questions is hard to
answer generally but this is
an example all right he weakens the dark
surface
like i said chess is a game of tip for
todd you have to give something up
you have to constantly be weighing the
positives and negatives you can't play a
chess game
where every single move has no negatives
that's not possible
prophylaxis is just stopping your
opponent's threats that's what it means
all right so f5 we take it and the rest
is very simple attack the knight win the
knight
and uh take with the king to facilitate
and accelerate
the pace at which the stroke is involved
what about h6 instead of g6 um well h6
doesn't stop
f5 i get what you're trying to do the
bishop could go to f4
you're you're not getting you're getting
at the the symptoms but not the root
cause
okay how do you know which side to
castle well you just choose the side
that's safest i mean here
the queen side is not entirely safe but
fine
king's side would be like castling into
a war zone thank you tolerandini
all right what if we had traded on d3
and played queen 85 a6
that's a typical idea saying yeah yeah
well jinga hurts thank you
well in terms of the question of whether
or not oh sorry the board got misaligned
whether or not to open up the center you
got to decide
sort of a rough way of thinking about
this is that the center is closed
the side that is attacking on a fling
doesn't want the center to open
if the center is closed and you have an
attack against your opponent's king
and you don't necessarily want to break
open the center because that would
dilute your attention right vice versa
if
you are getting attacked or you've
completed your development and you're
not
sure what to do and you feel like your
pieces are better placed than your
opponent's pieces opening up the center
could allow that
to you know to be more pronounced
uh but it's these are very general
guidelines
you just a lot of stuff you have to
evaluate on a case by case basis
okay all right um
well if you went g4 before we developed
our knights h6 then we give them a check
we pick off the pawn thank you gigahertz
five gifted and another one to texas a
tiger thanks man all right guys